at the end of this debate he instead
resumed today you will mercier matussek
in fact he sat circus that yes they are
tex prime there was a tiff and api form the
subject seven years consales telepass and
feedback in are all he was president
junker college members thank you
again  for being here for your
commitment to the defense of the
European ideal and on behalf of the parliament I
present our respect and
gratitude for the work you have
done and the dedication you have
shown for Europe thank you
[Music]
there is
[  Applause]
thank you let's interrupt for a moment to
then continue with the voting
thank you
kristie kolic looking in the mirror the weekend
continues james